hey everyone I'm Ilana and welcome to my
channel went today we was talking all
about the lost of his pot - I've played
it it's right here this is the title
screen I'm publishing this right in time
for reviewing bongos I can talk about
everything that is on to those
guidelines and I basically instead of
doing a review just decided to take a
bunch of questions from people on my
Instagram so I can pretty much cover
everything except I do want to say in
case nobody else says it I think this
review embargo for the loss of his pot -
is really restrictive or at least
restrictive of some things that I
consider to be important so reviews are
going to be allowed to publish at the
same time that this video publishes and
I would frankly wait until you get the
second wave of reviews next Thursday
because there are some things that you
had to agree not to talk about in
exchange for a code from PlayStation and
it's not like massive stuff there are
certain story related things which I
totally get they want to keep the story
as pure for people as possible you have
to remember vast majority of people who
are gonna play this game haven't seen
any of the leaks I have not seen any of
the leaks it wasn't too hard to avoid
nor would they even have heard of them
it's one of the most pre-ordered games
ever so I get wanting to keep things
secret but there are by virtue of their
being story things are not allowed to
talk about gameplay things that you also
can't talk about which I've never seen
in a review guideline before in exchange
for accepting a code so even if I want
friends with Troy Baker which makes me
not want to review this game anyway for
anyone who doesn't know he plays Joel we
have a podcast on this very channel
every week together I also just wouldn't
have done it until next week anyway
because of these restrictions so that
does mean that I can't answer most
questions except for the ones that are
bought by said restrictions also full
disclosure because you know I figured I
wasn't going to review it I haven't
finished it I'm about halfway probably a
bit at the halfway at this point so
let's just jump into it miss to steal my
own girl simply yes ah no no joke at all
was it fun no here's the thing about the
loss of his pot - that I respect the
most okay first things first the
gameplay is way better than the first
lost of us I just went back and played a
little bit of it for comparison it's so
much better it's better than uncharted 4
it's better
shotted loss legacy and there has not
even been that much time in between
those games this is absolutely in terms
of gameplay Naughty Dog's best game
without a doubt however because of the
themes and the story it isn't
necessarily a fun experience its
harrowing and brutal and unsettling in a
lot of ways and I do want to say that I
respect them for doing that we have this
idea that the be-all and end-all of
video games is fun and I don't think
that's necessarily true there are movies
that you watch that are not fun to watch
but they're moving and they mean
something but they are not necessarily
fun is the gameplay enjoyable absolutely
yes I really like it and I was actually
not particularly hot on the gameplay in
the first game is it a fun experience no
I wouldn't say that the loss of his
party was fun
it could follow up how's the story the
story is really complicated and I don't
want to spoil it the story is I think in
a lot of ways deep and heartfelt and
like I said harrowing and serious and
angry it's very much a story of revenge
but I think it develops further than
that it does become more about human
reflection probably same token there are
some issues that I take with the writing
I'm so curious to see where reviews
landed because the biggest issue that I
had is that a lot of their relationships
just aren't very interesting to me so
the bonds between the characters just
pale in comparison to the bond that is
built in the first game between Joel and
Ellie of course and a lot of the new
characters which of course it makes
sense that there are loads of new
characters I don't have any beef with
that but I just don't feel like they
flush out those bonds as well because I
just wasn't attached to anyone really
very much or any of the new people at
least so I think the first game has a
better story but I feel like then that's
such a big thing to say but I also feel
like it's one of the best video game
stories ever and I never expected the
loss was part two to where that's
concerned keep pace with the first game
that seemed impossible to me and I do
have some issues with the story in part
two not grabbing me anywhere near as
much as I would have liked but it is
still absolutely well written and well
paced and explores themes that I'm glad
videogames are exploring and I'm
talking about the gay stuff okay sure
they'll be a question in here somewhere
about the gay stuff in my opinion none
of that is explicit or over-the-top or
shoved in your face so feels like it's
SJW trash there are just gay characters
it doesn't it doesn't it didn't feel in
any way artificial or force to me at all
but maybe that's just me Adrienne
Williams said how is the tool slash
character customization compared to the
first game the RPG mechanics wait make
way more sense to me and I love though
the pacing of them - it's really really
fast upgrading things is really quick
it's not like it's the most extensive
thing on the wall because it's not an
RPG but I am very happy with the
customisation options gonna get official
what did Jay say one of my major issues
with tou one was the moment-to-moment
gameplay felt so lackluster in
comparison to the cutscenes almost like
they were making you play the boring
parts of the movie do you feel like the
balance between being a fun game and a
cinematic experience is better this time
around I kinda already touched on this
but I generally agree with you did not
like the gameplay the first game that
much loved the story no gameplay is way
more polished now there there's a lot of
like peaceful moments to where you're
just solving puzzles in a beautiful
environment and it is beautiful it's so
pretty but the actual moment-to-moment
gameplay is yeah a lot of exploring
looking at stuff that is very pretty but
the combat sequences are just so much
more polished really tense really open
environment so there are so many more
options for how you approach something
in that The Last of Us one I would
frequently want to take breaks from the
gameplay and I knew that I was driving
myself forward for the cutscenes the
loss of his pot - I getting excited when
I see a big open room and I know there
are going to be enemies there the
stealth is just so much more refined I
really really like this top options
frankly if you watch the stay to play
you know most of this but you know you
can duck in Tolga Ross didn't see a
single Pokemon devastatingly to get
stealth options you know you have to
identify which kind of infected are in
front of you to figure out how you want
to approach the environment or which
humans are in which position and their
AI is pretty unpredictable too and also
in some instance your companions will
help you take out infected without you
having a like command them
but they actually can be useful this was
inconsistent sometimes they wouldn't do
[ __ ] but a lot of the time they would be
helpful so yes I feel like the combat
being just so much more polished
tactical it just doesn't have that like
kind of slow sluggish jank enos that I
feel like the first game had a little
bit of where it wouldn't do what I
wanted it to do just because it was a
little role because this is really
flipped on its head for me I think
playing this game is is a much better
experience
David Conway said were the leaks real
like I said I managed to avoid them
I got a gist of some things based on you
know I'm currently talking about this
game on my podcast or on social media or
whatever but I didn't have any actual
spoilers from what I can tell there is
one leak that was really pushed hard
that is not real whole Cataldi said is
it as atmospheric as the first game does
it have the same level of emotion
absolutely yes maybe better emotion
because you're not dealing with Ellie
being stupid and standing up in the
middle of a fight or like while you're
like trying to sneak up on a click oh
they ironed all that stuff out so yes it
is extremely atmospheric and extremely a
massive this game so conflicting to talk
about because in in those ways I feel
like like in terms of atmosphere
specifically especially for not being a
horror game it is one of the most
atmospheric experiences ever you still
find notes scattered around the worlds
that have the people's lost moments
detail just that beautiful environmental
storytelling in Walled building that
Naughty Dog us so good at plus just
really really really detailed
environments you want characters houses
or you walk around busted buildings in
Seattle and and nothing is empty nothing
feels empty everything feels lived-in
and it almost feels like it was lived in
by you know a fully realized character
even if this is a little like outpost
with just a generator in it it really
feels like somebody manned that at some
point and they left that notes there and
they left and it makes you think about
what was this person doing when this all
went down when this when that's outbreak
of code when the wall went to [ __ ]
nobody talked I was so good at that
yes incredibly atmospheric stavi vet
said I'm not sure if that's why we sing
and I'm sorry I been needing a good cry
for a while now we'll pop to deliver yes
this game has some emotional moments
that really punch
in the gut miss keikain said is there a
multiplayer mode like the first had so I
feel like a lot of people must have
missed this announcement somehow which
is Obama yes there is a multiplayer
component of the last of his pot - but
it doesn't ship with this single-player
game in theory it is shipping like a
separate game Mass of us said is there a
difficulty setting yes there are I think
six options how much ammo is there
around can you run and gun it or do you
have to kind of sneak around most the
time you do have to sneak around most
the time as far as resource management
is concerned some enemy types are really
easy to one-hit kill it's not difficult
obviously it's going to be more
efficient if you're using stealth but
yes you would absolutely run out of ammo
if you try to just run in and kill
everyone Wallops said is this game more
open wild than you expected yes and in a
really smart way it's not open-world it
is a linear game but there are a bunch
of open walled sections the biggest Maps
we've ever seen in any naughty dog game
for sure and the the map design is
really cool you like pick up a real
world map and then Ellie will actually
mock things on it and then you pull that
up to be like okay I've been here it's
got a strike through it you have to
actually navigate with a map properly
because the UI is really limited you
really only have your guns on-screen
which I really love but yes some of
those environments are huge there aren't
necessarily things in all of those
environments but they can be massive and
I also really like the way that they box
you in can be really pretty it doesn't
like you know that you're not gonna be
able to walk in a certain direction but
it doesn't just look like an invisible
wall or like the map just falls off they
they taper everything off in a really
smart beam way again I went back and
played the lost of uh spot one just to
comparison because we're calling it pop
one now but just for comparison earlier
this week and that's one thing that
stands out as being massively different
is I kind of forgot how linear the first
game actually is and I love this
question Jo Ribeiro asked how loud does
the ps4 get I'm using my pro the one
that's that's just that a desk writing
Pro actually not that bad it does get
really hot but the fan is not too bad
Seraph Brad James said assuming it's
implemented as an in-game it can't
feature sorry how well does the guitar
playing walk is a mechanic I think it's
like really silly like yes guitar
playing is a thing you can do in the
game
it's kind of just like a sealing
minigame really it doesn't have any
weight I don't feel like it's
implemented as a mechanic in any
interesting way and pretty much all the
other questions I have here around the
same lines like there are a lot of
questions but they're all more or less
the same I guess it's one here saying
how do you think the camera controls
compared to the last one it's much
better it's really good I have no
complaints about the camera which means
it's a good camera generally aah
Godzilla said straight up did you like
it
yes I like this game I'm so glad the
combat is as refined and smooth as it is
the world is awesome and there are
things in it even though I do not feel
like it's perfect but there are things
in this game that I think like master
Kloss no need aughh
he's a very good studio and that about
wraps it up ladies and gentleman I feel
like I covered pretty much all the bases
here um a lot of physics stuff that I'm
really impressed by that kind of touched
on but I want to reiterate I really like
the music the sound design is fantastic
use of lighting is really good it is
technically such an impressive game
plenty more Last of Us coverage coming
I'm gonna be streaming the game from 5
a.m. next Thursday Pacific time we'll
have a spoiler cast up with a couple of
my journalist friends who have very
strong opinions on this game and I'll
probably turn the stream into a series
of Let's Plays for anyone accomplished
live so lots of content coming thank you
all for watching and thank you for
asking questions and I will see you all
next time